we begin this newshour with breaking
news out of austria prosecutors are
investigating chancellor sebastian curse
on suspicion of corruption and bribery
his offices were raided earlier today
nine other people are also being
investigated let's bring in dominique
kane who's in berlin forest dominic
what's this all about
this is all about the suspicion of
corruption that has been placed as it
were at the door of the chancellor
sebastian kurtz it refers to the
activity of a particular tabloid
newspaper in austria during the course
of the past few years but specifically
what's under investigation is what took
place between the years 2016 and 2018.
this is the suggestion the suspicion
indeed that prosecutors are working
under is that mr kurtz and or the nine
other people involved in this
investigation the people being
investigated
were involved in the commission of
certain offences around bribery
specifically it is alleged and it is
suspected by prosecutors that mr kurtz
and others
brought influence on the editorial board
of this particular newspaper in austria
to procure preferential coverage of mr
kurtz and his party such that an opinion
poll was put out by this newspaper which
cast mr kurtz's party in a very
preferential light and it wasn't put out
as an advertisement it should have been
say prosecutors that it should have been
put out as an advertisement the point
being that the allegation the suspicion
put forward by prosecutors in austria
this afternoon
is
that
the
publication of the poll was put out in a
newspaper not as an advertisement as it
should have been and that the other side
of this is that certain individuals in
that newspaper in that editorial side of
things were then procured
positions on the board of a specific
company now the suggestion being put
forward by prosecutors is that federal
finance was involved in this that means
government money i.e taxpayers money the
significance of this mr quartz has been
in power now since the end of 2017 he
lost his previous government partner
in 2019 uh viewers will remember in the
course of a corruption scandal involving
that other party the far-right party in
austria mr courts came back as it were
from the political debt and won that
election but this is the first time he
has found himself personally under
investigation for corruption bribery
clearly he denies these allegations but
he is under investigation and he is one
of ten people him and nine others who
are now under suspicion of bribery
relating to that newspaper so sebastian
kurz directly being investigated this
time as you say as well as other
conservatives
what
does he risk how much damage could this
cause him
on the face of it the suspicion of the
commission of an offense is not the same
thing as being charged with the offence
and therefore having to go
to court and to have to face those
any charges that might ensue we must be
very clear this is the start
from a
juridical perspective this is the start
from a legal perspective this is the
start of anything that might develop
into anything so it is possible that
this may not lead to charges to an
appearance in court and anything that
might flow from that but clearly if it
were to do that then that would put mr
cuts in very particular jeopardy clearly
politically the question now would be
both for his party and for his coalition
partners currently in government
well what do they make of this are they
happy at the thought that the man who is
currently chancellor who won the last
general election with a big personal
vote as it were is under investigation
for what would on the face of it be
serious criminal offences lots of
questions then
not just for the investigators right now
but also for the political backers of mr
kurtz do they want uh to have the
problems that these these investigations
are going to provoke because clearly
this is going to be a very very big
political story in vienna in the rest of
austria because mr courts on the face of
it opinion polls suggests that he is
certainly preeminent in terms of the
voters
approval ratings how will voters respond
to these allegations where will they go
next very many questions right now not
so many answers and we'll continue to
follow all the latest developments with
you dominique kane live there in berlin